we're with world champion Magnus Carlsen
Magnus how do you feel about your play
in the game well I think it was a bit
embarrassing for both of us he screwed
up pretty quickly he all playing me and
then just hanging on trying you know not
to lose immediately he messed up a bit
then he messed up even more and I
probably had a winning position well it
looked with blizzard looked very
promising but then yeah I couldn't find
it he gots enough David Tua to make a
draw and specifically how did he mess up
was it the toggling of his king or was
it something more specific than that
he already messed up when he I think
when I sort of managed this g5 and to
two holes there but then Luke III was
pretty bad and after that maybe you can
play actively somehow and for us to draw
it's already it's already pretty
unpleasant for him
you seem to have gotten black against
him nearly every time since your World
Championship match do you feel like
that's been a bit unlucky yeah it's
alright
I mean these are all strong players and
have to be black feeding some some of
them
final question you guys have played
probably more than anybody over the last
two years you're a big fan of sports is
this kind of like rocky versus Apollo or
do you have a better metaphor for us
today was to punch drunk idiots thanks
very much for your time the thoughts
about the world champion now back to the
studio